you gave a lot of credit to i think
caltech and mit for some of the
technical developments like within this
project
is there some interesting things you can
speak to
like
at the low level of some cool stuff that
to be solved like what are we yeah yeah
i'm a software engineer so okay all of
this i have so much more respect for
everything done here than anything i've
ever done so it's just code so
so i'll give you
an example of doing uh
uh
mechanical engineering
and a better look at
a
basically mechanical engineering and
geology and maybe at a
level okay uh so what do we what's the
problem the problem is the following
that i've given you this picture of an
instrument that i by some magic i can
make good enough to measure this very
short distance
but then i put it down here
it won't work and the reason it doesn't
work
is that the earth itself is moving all
over the place all the time you don't
realize it it seems pretty good to you i
get it but it's moving all the time so
somehow
it's moving so much that you we can't
deal with it we happen to be trying to
do the experiment here on earth
but we can't deal with it so we have to
make the instrument
isolated from the earth
oh no
at the frequencies we're at we've got to
float it that's a mechanical that's an
engineering problem not a physics
problem so when you actually
like uh we're doing we're having a
conversation on a podcast right now
there's uh and people record music work
with this you know how to create an
isolated room
and they usually build a room within a
room
but that's still not isolated in fact
they say it's impossible to truly
isolate from sound from noise and stuff
like that
but that that
that's like one step of
millions that you took
is building a room inside a room because
you basically have to isolate all now
this is actually an easier problem you
just have to do it really well so
making a clean room is really a tough
problem because you have to put a room
inside a room yeah you have to
so this is this is really simple
engineering or physics uh-huh okay so
what do you have to do how do you
isolate yourself from the from the earth
yes
first we work at
uh we're not looking at all frequencies
for gravitational waves we're looking at
particular frequencies
that you can deal with here on earth
so what frequencies would those be
you were just talking about frequencies
i mean i don't we know by evolution our
bodies know it's the audio band
okay the reason our ears work where they
work is that's where the earth isn't
going making too much noise okay so the
reason our ears work the way they work
is because this is where it's quiet
that's right
so if you go to if you go to one hertz
instead of 10 hertz
it's the earth is
it's really moving around
so
so somehow we live in a what we call the
audio band it's tens of hertz to
thousands of hertz that's where we
live that's where we live okay
if we're going to do an experiment on
the earth i might as well do this it's
the same frequency that's where the
earth is the quietest so we have to work
in that frequency so we're not looking
at all frequencies okay
so the solution for the for the shaking
of the earth to get rid of it is pretty
mundane if we do the same thing
that you do
to make your car drive smoothly down the
road so what happens when your car goes
over a bump
early cars did that they bounced right
okay but you don't feel that in your car
so what happened to that energy you
can't just disappear energy so we have
these things called shock absorbers in
the car
what they do
is they absorb they take the the thing
that went like that and they basically
can't get rid of the energy but they
move it to very very low frequency
so what you feel isn't
you feel like go shh
smoothly okay
all right so uh
we also work at this frequency so if we
so we basically why
wh why do we have to do anything other
than shock absorbers so we made
the world's fanciest shock absorbers
okay
not just like in your car where there's
one layer of them they're just the right
squishiness and so forth they're better
than what's in the cars
and we have four layers of it so
whatever shakes and gets through the
first layer we treat it in a second
third
layer so it's a mechanical engineering
problem yeah that's what i said so
it's not there's no weird tricks to it
like uh like a chemistry type thing or
no no just well the right squishiness
here i need the right material inside
and ours look like little springs but
they're
springs they're springs so like
legitimately like shock absorbers yeah
what
okay okay
and this is now experimental physics at
the at its limit okay so you do this and
we make the world's fanciest shock
absorbers just mechanical engineering
just mechanical genius is hilarious but
we didn't we weren't good enough to
discover gravitational waves
so
so we did another we added another
feature and it's something else that
you're
aware of probably have one
and that is to get rid of noise you've
probably
noise which is you don't like
and that's the same principle that's in
these little bose uh
uh earphones noise cancelling
noise cancelling so
so how do they work they basically you
go on an airplane and they
uh sense the ambient noise from the
engines
and cancel it because it's just the same
over and over again they cancel it and
when the stewardess comes and asks you
whether you want coffee or a tea or a
drink or something you hear her fine
because she's not ambient she's a signal
so are we talking about active canceling
like where they actually have cancelling
so this is you okay so another don't
tell me you have active canceling uh on
this yeah besides the show absolutely so
we had this so inside this
array of shock absorbers yeah we you
asked for some interesting this is
awesome
so inside this it's harder than the the
earphone problem but it's just
engineering we have to see measure not
just that the
uh engine still made noise
but the earth is shaking it's moving in
some direction so we have to actually
tell not only that there's noise and
cancel it but what direction it's from
so we put this array of seismometers
inside
this array of shock absorbers and
measure the residual
motion
and its direction
and we put little actuators that push
back against it and cancel it
this is awesome
so you have the actuators and you have
the thing that is sensing the the
vibrations and then you have the actual
actuators that adjust for that and do so
in perfect synchrony yeah
what if it all works right and so how
much do we reduce the shaking of the
earth
i mean
one part in 10 to the 12th
one part
inside what gets through us is one part
and 10 to the 12th
that's pretty big reduction you don't
need that in your car but that's what we
do and so that's how isolated we are
from the earth and that was the biggest
uh
i'd say technical problem outside of the
physics instrument the interferometer
that's a weird question here you make it
very poetically and humorously it's
saying it's just a mechanical
engineering problem
but is this one of the
biggest
precision
mechanical engineering efforts ever
i mean this seems exceptionally
difficult it is and so it took a long
time and uh i think
nobody seems to challenge the statement
that this is the most precision precise
instrument that's ever been built like
them
i just i wonder what like listening to
led zeppelin sounds on this thing
because it's so isolated i mean this is
like
uh
i don't know no background noise nope no
back it's wow
wow wow that so when you were first
conceiving this um
i would probably uh if i was
knowledgeable enough kind of uh laugh
off the possibility this is even
possible i'm sure
like how many people
believe that this is possible did you
believe oh oh uh i did
uh
i didn't know that we needed for sure
that we needed active when we started we
did just passive but we were doing the
tests to develop the active
to add as a second stage which we ended
up needing
um
but there was a lot of
you know now now there was a lot of
skepticism a lot of us especially
astronomers
felt that money was being wasted because
we were all so expensive
doing what i told you is not cheap so it
was
kind of controversial it was funded by
the national science foundation
can you just linger on this just for a
little longer the actuator thing the
active canceling
um
do you remember
like little experiments that were done
along the way to prove to the team to
themselves that this is even possible
so from our
because i work with quite a bit of
robots
and to me the idea that you could do it
this precisely
is uh humbling and embarrassing
frankly because like this is another
level of precision that i can't even
um because robots are a mess
and this is basically
one of the most precise robots ever
right so like uh can you is there uh
yeah do you have any like small scale
experiments that were done that's just
believe this is possible yeah and larger
scale we made we made uh test uh
chain that also has to be in vacuum too
but we made test chambers that had this
system
in it our first mock of this system that
so we could test it
and uh
optimize it and make it work but it's
just a mechanical engineering problem
okay
[Laughter]
uh and humans are just ape descendants i
got you
i got you uh is there any video of this
like um
some kind of educational purpose
visualizations of this act of canceling
and uh i don't think so
i mean is this does this live on
well we work for parts of it for the
active canceling we worked with for the
instruments for the sensor and
instruments we worked with
a small company and met near where you
are because it was our mit people that
got them that were you know interested
in the problem because they thought they
might be able to commercialize it for
making stable tables to make
microelectronics for example which are
limited by the how stable the table is
i mean at this point it's a little
expensive so you never know you never
know where this leads
you